who wants america to get weaker outside
of forget about the enemies what i'm
talking about is you the name that comes
up often is what what are your thoughts
about the world economic forum you know
in the world health organizations and
these organizations that kind of stand
alone and yeah they're here for the
world and you know you'll hear the name
coming up with claus schwab and you know
where he's at and what he's trying to do
and you know the new world order where
do you stand with that when you hear
that
well the left and uh the globalists want
america to get weaker
uh you know
uh that's been a divide i think that
wasn't really appreciated until trump
came along okay
uh you know with his america first
policy which is anathema to
establishment washington uh that's
because these people aren't nationalists
they're globalists
they want to use american power they
want to use america as an engine to
realize a a a a a a a globalist
a world order you know that's dominated
by supranational institutions like the
united nations and the world courts and
world economic forums and the elites who
run these things will be making the
decisions for us
you know and uh uh whenever they
try to encourage us and and
most of the wars that we've been
fighting in recent decades
have this globalist agenda you know uh
the war in ukraine the reason we're
there is because
we want uh
we want people to think we want the
nations to think that warfare is
obsolete that in the 21st century you
can't
uh fight wars and you shouldn't be
acting on national interests the way
russia is okay uh that you that you need
to subordinate your concept of national
interests to this larger
agenda the globalists believe
uh and the left that nationalism is evil
you know that it is responsible for the
wars of the past and the way of getting
into a peaceful ordered world uh is by
subordinate subordinating nationalism
and maybe
evolving past it altogether the concept
of the world citizen
that's why
our borders are wide open okay this uh
because that implies
a nationalism that implies you know
old-fashioned nation-states they want
open borders uh they want supernational
institutions running everything
and uh a lot of the wars that don't make
sense to most americans because most
americans are nationalists and our
america first
are
and they say
why are we in afghanistan why are we in
iraq uh the rationalization there are
rationalizations that are concocted
uh to appeal to them and say well we're
in afghanistan because of the war on
terrorism because we don't want the bad
guys to come and attack the united
states again from afghanistan and that
was the rationalization there
and the rationalization for going into
ukraine
our involvement in ukraine is well we
don't want russia and china uh you know
to attack our allies and uh and us
interests in world war three and and
that
makes sense
to a lot of americans it makes enough
sense so that we've been willing to
support wars like that okay but is that
the real reason the elites are going
into these wars
uh no that's not the real reason you
know the real reason is uh is uh
uh is these globalist explanations the
idea that uh uh you know that any nation
that violates another nation's
sovereignty has to be punished and
therefore america is going to be the
world policeman on behalf of these
supranational institutions enforcing you
know this new globalist world order and
that's why
that's why the biden administration
uh
uh and uh and and the european union and
the nato alliance that's why they're in
ukraine it's because of the uh
of these uh
so we have elites who use nationalist
rationalizations to convince the people
to try to
convince the people yeah we need to stay
and keep staying in afghanistan forever
and forever
uh but you can also see a lot of the
agenda there for example in afghanistan
i mean how was it serving our interests
to
to want to turn afghanistan not not only
to quell the taliban okay but we were we
were trying to turn them into a feminist
secular democracy okay and have the
values of the globalists imposed on a
country like afghanistan which is
clearly an impossible
uh thing to do and uh you know uh you
know afghanistan is
you know it never went through the
enlightenment it never went through the
renaissance it didn't have an industrial
none of the historical things happened
to make it
that happened in western europe to make
possible a democratic secular feminist
democracy you know and yet uh you know
the nation building you know the notion
of nation building itself is really
globalist nation building you know
building the nation
uh with value systems
uh uh that uh that are embraced by the
globalists uh so you've gotta this is
the dilemma and i think
americans are waking up to it
that their leaders
despite what they say to them about
their agenda you know in these countries
where they appeal to our patriotism to
get involved in a war that really they
have ulterior motives that have to do
with uh globalist interests that are not
the same and oftentimes are opposed to
what u.s vital national interests are
and and i think ukraine is a great
example of that you know the vital
national interest of national interest
of the united states right now is to not
get in a nuclear war with russia that
could destroy the united states that's
more important than anything but our
policy is acting like that doesn't
matter at all and that we can just keep
doing and pushing and and uh
and why you know and that's because
american national interests are not
first and foremost in ukraine it's the
globalist agenda you know russia's got
to be punished for trying to protect its
national interests what it perceives is
its national interests and its empire
building in ukraine and uh and they've
got to be brought to heal
and uh and and uh and what is the
solution though to just stay out of the
way and let them uh
is a solution let them do whatever they
want to do with ukraine and we do
nothing is that the solution
well in the end we may not be able to
have any control but
my solution but you know what i think we
should do
you know uh by biden i think should uh
uh should mobilize u.s nuclear forces
and put them at least on defcon 3 right
even though putin put his nuclear forces
on alert back on february 27th okay
you know
historically whenever the russians have
done that
we
increase we mobilize our forces so that
they're in a more survivable posture you
know we have no choice we're supposed to
do that because we don't want them to be
able to do nuclear pearl harbor on us
but the blind administration has broken
precedent and has left our forces at
defcon 5 which is the lowest readiness
level and they're saying well we don't
see any evidence that the russians have
really mobilized their forces which is a
lie because there's actually all kinds
of evidence that putin
has mobilized those forces and uh and
those forces actually don't even have to
be all that mobilized because the
russian strategic forces are designed to
make a surprise attack
24 7 all the time they're on a condition
called constant combat readiness
and uh and so when conditions exist
where russia hasn't may have a reason to
launch a surprise nuclear attack we need
to mobilize our forces to survivable
posture so one of the first things i
would do is i would mobilize those
forces go at least to defcon three
so that it would make it harder for them
to do a nuclear pearl harbor you know
we're offering there next to them right
now and then i would immediately inform
putin and say
we're mobilizing our forces you've left
us no choice we've got to do it because
you mobilized your forces and we've
exercised great patience you know we've
been waiting for you to come down with
uh with your forces but you haven't so
uh we're not planning to attack you but
you've left us no choice okay
and uh
neither of us wants to have a nuclear
world war uh you know so
let's try to eliminate the problem and
negotiate a peace in ukraine right now
uh and we and and and i'm willing to
negotiate with you on the basis of the
uh peace treaty that you had offered to
the united states and nato europe before
you invaded ukraine let's go back and
we'll negotiate i'm not going to say
that we're going to give you all your
points but there are many points in that
peace treaty that are just as much in
our interests as they are in nato's
interests excuse me in russia's
interests uh for example you know
not bringing ukraine into nato you know
uh you know yes we're gonna we're gonna
give you that we're not gonna expand
nato further eastward so all these
partnership for peace countries that
kazakhstan tajikistan kurdica stand
south easter you know uh uh all these uh
countries that are in on on the way to
becoming nato members you know because
they're in a partnership for peace we'll
we're gonna give we're gonna give you
that those are examples of
of things that i would readily agree to
in the treaty so there's a lot that
could be
could be given up
and uh
uh
and uh
i would try to use the negotiations
beyond achieving peace in ukraine
uh i would try to use the negotiations
uh to hit the reset button with the
relations with russia you know because
uh our real objective should be to split
the russian chinese alliance you know we
face the most formidable block of
military and economic power that we've
ever faced in our history this new axis
that comprises not just russia and china
united but north korea and iran too
they're all part of this
anti-western bloc
and i don't think we can win a new cold
war or a world war iii against that
block of power
they have uh not only do they have the
economic and military advantages but
they have the advantage of political
will these are the totalitarian and
authoritarian states there they've been
willing to sacrifice millions of their
own people building socialism they would
be willing to sacrifice far many more
people than we would to win a world war
iii against us we don't want to get into
that situation so we need to
we need to
we need to split that russian chinese
alliance
as a way of pulling the whole world back
from the edge of a war and turn it into
a new cold war a competition that's
economic and diplomatic and political
not a military confrontation and so i
would use the negotiations over ukraine
to try to hit the reset button with
russia and make them at least neutral
okay in the new cold war with china or
even a strategic partner because i think
putin
i think putin was willing to do that
during the trump administration you know
i think putin knows that in the long run
china is a bigger threat to russia than
the west and that he's better off he
knows that i think he knows that i think
it's obvious you know when you when you
look at
world what's up exactly
well what's obvious is that russia has a
shared border with china has a
diminishing population and the
diminishing economy china is greedy for
the natural resources including in
siberia and territory i think putin
knows that the russians are chess
players you know that after world war
iii suppose there is a world war three
and that defeat us okay there's going to
be a world war iv and that's going to be
between
the new access
you know russia and china will confront
each other in that world war iv and i
don't think putin wants that i think
he'd rather
he'd rather be a strategic partner with
the west and avoid both a world war iii
and a world war iv if possible uh if he
could hit that reset button and have us
as a partner to protect russia against
china and i think putin all through the
trump administration was waiting for
trump to hit the reset button that was
their plan that was what general flynn
was advising before he got
you know got fired over over that
nonsense and uh
uh you know but trump was not ever in a
position politically where he could make
it happen the democrat party you know
made it impossible for president trump
to do this
to take this step that was vital to our
national security to try to hit the
reset button with russia you know
they're click cues into being putin's
puppet and uh and and
and uh and uh uh and it wasn't
politically possible for him to do it
that uh but we could do it if we were
now if we were negotiating over ukraine
uh
uh you know
we try to protect ukrainian interests
you know as much as as much as we could
it helps that that the ukraine
apparently has been prevailing a lot of
these areas you know i don't think that
we're going to be able to get uh you
know the don bass back uh any areas that
the russians actually control you know
ukraine might have to resign itself to
becoming a rump state and in the long
run you know you create it may not be
possible to save ukraine at all you know
because russia is going to consider it a
vital geostrategic interest of its but
at least temporarily you know uh uh you
know in uh uh
at least temporarily uh because ukraine
has had good fortune in the war
you know uh
we would have been able to buy some time
for ukraine but my
concern is not ukraine you know america
has no vital interest in ukraine except
avoiding the nuclear war with russia and
gaining and and if we can turn lemons
into lemonade and gain a strategic
partnership with russia
our vital interest is avoiding nuclear
war with russia
and getting them to be a neutral or a
strategic partner in the new cold war
with china so that we can prevail in the
new cold war with china or world war iii
if that becomes necessary
and that's and that's what i would do
and i think people would be surprised
that despite all of the the rhetoric and
all the rest uh all the angst over over
the ukraine war
i think uh we might be pleasantly
surprised at how quickly you know russia
is willing to and they maybe might even
be willing to make temporary very
significant concessions over ukraine in
order to have that strategic partnership
with the west so that they're not in a
a doomed partnership with china a
partnership with china that's ultimately
going to doom russia even if they win
world war iii because they won't
probably win world war iv against china
and by the way that's why china is
rapidly building up its nuclear forces
you know right now china needs russia
because russia is the dominant nuclear
power in the world by far
but china is building up nuclear
capabilities so that
by or before 2030
they will be a nuclear challenge to
russia those nuclear weapons i think are
aimed they are aimed at us but i think
china's thinking about world war 4 too
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]
you